next up my journey 600 feet into the
crater of a volatile Inferno where
scientists are looking for signs that
could end up saving thousands of lives
Masaya in nicaragua is so feared that
religious crusaders once tried to
exorcise the devil out of its heart lake
nicaragua the largest body of fresh
water in Central America and home to he
Goro Island a National Geographic unique
Lodge Nicaragua has 19 active volcanoes
including Messiah a ticking time bomb
that could go off at any moment that's
where I'm headed just look at the size
of this volcanic crater it's about seven
miles across and in the center of it
another volcano was born Messiah one of
the most volatile in the world that's
erupted 13 times in just the last 30
years I'm making my where around the
crater of masaya volcano to some
volcanologist who risk their lives out
here on this deadly beast part of what
makes volcanoes so dangerous is that
they're unpredictable and no one really
knows when this one will erupt again
with a million people living just 15
miles away geologists have set up shop
in the heart of this ticking time bomb
to figure that out guys
nice to see you working on one of the
sensors yes feel yes we're thinking
currently maintenance of the gas
instruments that we used to monitor the
mouth of hell yeah name come from by the
way that's from the Spanish
conquistadors you know yeah they thought
that it was gold in fire coming from
hell
so that's why it's named amando and his
team monitor a network of 80 sensors
gauging messiah's conditions and
surrounding atmosphere so they can try
to predict the next eruption it seems to
me that without these warning systems
the people would be really vulnerable
this is the only means of defense for
them as you say when we detect something
that is dangerous we send information
immediately to the local authorities in
the spring of 2018 earthquake sensors
captured vital data on Hawaii's Kilauea
Volcano which after it erupted reduced
600 homes to ashes that Intel is crucial
to missions like this he's getting
unstable you can see
yeah the edge is starting to break away
he's falling apart
Oh My yes that's the mouth of hell oh my
god that is really scary-looking
where in the world can you see this very
few places yeah better people in the lab
O'Lakes that form in active volcanoes
typically don't last long but messiah's
has been churning consistently for
centuries making it one of the most
active members of the Ring of Fire
I've used some volcanic rocks to make a
very rough map but I want to show you
exactly where the Ring of Fire is it's
25,000 miles long it can completely
circumnavigates the Pacific Ocean it
runs right through New Zealand that's
why there's a lot of volcanoes there
through Indonesia Japan through the top
of Russia all the way down the west
coast of America and then down through
Central America where Nicaragua is and
it continues right down to the end of
South America almost all of the
volcanoes in the Ring of Fire occur
along the edges of the Pacific tectonic
plate but Messiah was formed between two
smaller plates about 20 million years
ago the Cocos plate began sliding under
the Caribbean plate the energy from this
subduction turns solid rock into liquid
magma and when that magma escaped
through the Earth's crust Messiah was
born
[Music]
it's a long way down so we're good
it's a 60-story drop into this cauldron
of toxic gas I'm going in to meet up
with Rodolfo Alvarez the engineer behind
this pulley system built to get
scientists in and out of this massive
crater
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
descending into this hostile environment
of heat from toxic gas is extremely
dangerous
but for Rodolfo Alvarez it's as if it's
just another day at the office
well welcome to excel oh my goodness
that was just insane your dog so quickly
why are you not wearing your gas mask
what's wrong with you because I wear it
when I need it how do you know you watch
the gas is coming up right I know you
don't need the mask but if you want to
keep it is no problem there is an
overwhelming odor down here like a match
that's just being lit that's sulfur
dioxide and when that gas mixes with the
moisture in the air it forms sulfuric
acid it eats everything from the cables
ferrying the team in and out of Mosiah
to the sensors that raise the alarm when
there's danger this is a box that we got
them to protect their sensors their
sensory and say because of that that's a
pure castle it's so high there are
little sensors down the bottom here a
difference definitely sensor for
different gases those are the ones I
have damaged the corrosion is really bad
yes I show you some Mason if you all
around I see in here I mean this is like
a cave and we can Wow look at these
joints have just completely eroded away
I mean it's completely destroyed and
that's from the sulfuric acid yes you
know you have all these flowers of
software and you can feel in your eyes
so you say your eyes are starting the
hell music yeah that's strong it is I
mean it's not beautiful uric acid but
it's very high percentage man I just
keep want to keep putting on the mask
and I look at you you got enough masks
on how you do it we can go that way and
you can actually get to the edge we have
robbed set up so you can
we're gonna go here how are you just got
this swirling of gases get a good look
I've never seen anything of this
magnitude and power and you can feel the
power in the ground what is it about the
lava that you love people are afraid of
this but this is what it really makes
you feel alive this is one of these
amazing of nature or the universe that
you can actually see in person
[Music]
[Music]